merry christmas everybody or to
everybody that celebrates christmas just
wanted to make a video and say hi and
say thank you for supporting me through
this year and watching my stuff i know
i've been doing some big projects oh and
before i continue i know the more
important thing is that i will be
finishing security breach tomorrow i
will actually be doing a live stream so
if you haven't caught up on the series
yet please do that way you can watch me
descend into madness right before your
very eyes as i try to finish the game um
but yeah just wanted to say thank you
for supporting me i've been doing a lot
of big projects this year i did the edge
of sleep and in space with markiplier
and i know you haven't seen those yet
and i honestly can't believe that you
will soon see in space with markiplier
because
i've been working on that for
god years now and it's so much bigger
than i ever thought it could be
and it's so much better
than i imagined it could be and i just
can't wait for you to see it
uh so yeah
just
thank you
and
a lot of cool stuff around the corner
i'm still constantly making things which
is a shock to me that i still feel just
as in love with making
cool as i did
so many years ago only now that i know
how to make cooler maybe well i
mean you'll be the judge of that but
honestly it's just been fun every day to
try to create
and do these crazy things so
thank you for giving me the chance i
hope you had a good enough year i know
it wasn't easy for anybody but i hope
you had a good enough one
and here's to a 2022
who knows how that's gonna be maybe
it'll be deja vu all over again
but i'll be here making stuff for you
so thank you for watching
happy holidays merry christmas
and i'll see you tomorrow
in the next video
bye-bye